joe biden gave his his speech in
wilmington delaware 70 feet from his
basement
and uh and he explained that it was time
to put away harsh rhetoric
says captain i'll put you all back in
chains and you ain't black if you don't
vote for joe biden
time to put away harsh rhetoric is it
here's joe biden
it's time to put away the harsh rhetoric
lower the temperature see each other
again
listen to each other again and to make
progress
we have to stop treating our opponents
as our enemies
they are not our enemies they are
americans the bible tells us
to everything there is a season a time
to build
a time to reap and a time to sow and a
time to heal
this is the time to heal in america it's
a time to heal guys
it's time to heal so here's the question
you should be asking yourself what kind
of healing are we talking about
joe are we talking about the kind of
healing where you acknowledge there are
people who disagree with you and then we
all decide to live together and leave
each other alone
because that's my kind of healing right
i like the kind of healing where
california gets to be as dumb as
california wants to be and florida gets
to be as awesome as florida gets to be
and if you're religious you get to be
religious and if you're secular you get
to be secular
and nobody puts their values on somebody
else's back
right that's kind honestly that's my
kind of living together
is where we have certain core values
like the protection of human life right
like
the free like freedom of speech freedom
of the press like the ones that are in
the constitution mainly and then we
mostly leave each other alone
or the values of the declaration of
independence we agree on that and then
we agree
to go our separate ways and we still
have a community because we are
connected by these basic ideas that's my
idea
of healing i don't think that's what joe
biden means by healing i think what joe
biden means by healing is here's my
democratic party agenda and if you
disagree with it you're not part of the
healing why aren't you part of the
healing i'm going to clock in the head
and let's be part of the healing
heal with me heal right i i don't think
this is going to be
an era of tolerance the fight is just
beginning we'll see this in just one
second when you see what the democratic
party who is not joe biden
is actually saying while joe biden is
out there putting a nice friendly
potemkin village facade on what is a
seething undercurrent
of rage inside the democratic party okay
so then joe biden talks about his
mandate this
i think this is my favorite part of joe
biden's little speech is where he talked
about
his uh his mandate as president it turns
out his mandate as president
is really i mean it just
that's the only way to describe it
because it means nothing it's
meaningless
it's meaningless slogans actually turns
out his mandate isn't
for a tax increase his mandate is not
for the green new deal
his mandate is not for any of his major
policy prescriptions
joe biden himself expresses it his
mandate is to be a nice man
which wow what a mandate big thing is
going to happen because joe biden
is a nice old man here's grandpa joe
what is our mandate i believe it's this
americans have called upon us to marshal
the forces of decency
the forces of fairness to marshal the
forces of science
and the forces of hope and the great
battles of our time
the battle control the virus the battle
of bill prosperity
the battle secure your family's health
care
the battle will achieve racial justice
and root out systemic racism in this
country
in the battle to save our planet by
getting climate under control
the battle restore decency defend
democracy
and gave everybody in this country a
fair shot
you got that that's a strong mandate
right there that's a strong mandate for
decency mcferron is mixed science
mchopey
right strong agenda right there science
make hopey mcfairness decency face
wow wow what a strong mandate not for a
specific agenda
mind you but to be a nice guy who cares
about things
not what what things any things like the
things like science and decency and
democracy and hope
and massages of random women and
smelling there are like lots of lots of
things like there's a mandate guys
okay now what's hilarious about that of
course is that he just says i won a
historic election
i won a historic election and now i have
a mandate a mandate to a hexagon of
families
trump elizabeth okay all right fine that
doesn't seem like a very strong mandate
but
sure go with it okay and then he pledges
again we're going to end the era of
demonization we're going to end the era
of demonization again
you know i don't even need to play more
job because it's the same message over
and over right i'm gonna work as hard
for
everybody as people if you didn't vote
for me i'm gonna work hard for you
and we're gonna get together and we're
gonna be best friends again
and we're gonna play disco it's gonna be
amazing guys
it's gonna we're gonna cure disease like
cancer and alzheimer's he said that he's
gonna cure cancer and
alzheimer's he's looking ahead to an
america that's freer and more just
that creates jobs with dignity and
respect and that cures diseases like
cancer and alzheimer's by the way
i will note a piece of odd timing pfizer
today today
announced that they have developed a
vaccine that is 90
effective at preventing coronavirus
infections they announced it today
weird timing and they wait until after
the weekend
when uh the media announced that joe
biden is president and then magically
just like the the clouds parting fizer
announces this count me slightly
suspicious like it's great news
but let me just point something out
donald trump was president when pfizer
got the money to develop that vaccine
that's a trump administration
accomplishment that is not a joe biden
accomplishment anyway
okay so that is the message of joe biden
right is that he has a mandate for
niceness and happiness and fairness and
brotherhood
and smoking dope and hanging out and
watching the moon rise and all that kind
of stuff right
it's gonna be hoping to change face part
two except weird and old and white
that's good it's gonna be fantastic okay
then there is
then there's the democratic party and
let me just say
when they say unity i don't think that
they mean that we get together and we
sing kumbaya
i think they mean unity like here's a
re-education camp
would you like to come this way then we
can be unified afterward
like fahrenheit 451 reunite
reunification
what if we could be unified because you
think like me
right so if joe biden wants to wants to
actually promote unity seriously this is
a serious thing now if joe biden wants
to promote unity
at some point he has to speak to his own
side here's the thing
in any relationship if you want there to
be
any sort of comedy between people you
have to go to the people who are
creating the vision on your own side and
tell them to knock it off
you have to have a sister soldier moment
bill clinton famously did this in 1992
there was a very little-known rapper
named sister soldier who said something
racially terrible about conflict between
the races
and clinton chided her right this was a
big moment he kind of picked her out of
a hat and went after her specifically in
order to have this
unity moment there were some of us
throughout the trump administration
who loved what trump was doing but we
were not super happy with a lot of the
divisive things that trump was saying
and we would call that out right
i've not seen one iota of that from the
democrats not one iota
not one okay like i'll believe that joe
biden wants unity when he says to
michelle obama knock it off
because here's what michelle obama
tweeted over the weekend right the heart
and soul of the democratic party she had
an instagram
post and here's what she put out in her
instagram post
voting in one election isn't a magic
wand and neither is winning one let's
remember
that tens of millions of people voted
for the status quo
even when it meant supporting lies hate
chaos and division
does that sound like a kumbaya message
to you does that sound like
she wants to understand people on the
other side or like she cares about
people on the other side
does that sound like michelle obama who
is in fact the oprah winfrey of the
democratic party right she is this
this mom of the democratic party who are
all supposed to respect her opinion
because she's so nice and wonderful
and and she's become she's moved from
being sort of a divisive figure in her
early iteration to this great unifying
figure the best-selling author in the
united states for the past several years
she literally says that tens of millions
of americans are motivated by hate
and division and chaos to maintain the
status quo
when is joe biden gonna say listen
michelle we need to have unity stop
saying that about your fellow americans
stop it right just stop it stop implying
that people
not implying saying openly that people
who disagree with you are motivated by a
willingness to ignore
hatred and brutality and evil and
nastiness just to maintain the status
quo
you think joe biden's gonna say any of
that of course jobin's not going to say
any of that because his own base is
clamoring for blood
they are being for political blood at
this point
i got jennifer rubin who used to be
labeled the conservative voice over at
the washington post which is hilarious
he said jennifer rubin went on msnbc
after the media declared joe biden
victorious and again there's a legal
process he's not in fact the
president-elect of the united states
yeah legally speaking
jennifer rubin went on there and she
turned into
fesic from princess bride they put her
in a holocaust cloak lit it on fire and
she starts going
there will be no survivors
here is jennifer rubin going completely
hogwild
it's not only that trump has to lose but
that all his enablers have to lose
they have to we have to collectively in
essence burn down the republican party
um we have to level them because if
there are survivors if there are people
who
weather this storm they will do it again
they will take this as confirmation that
hey
it just pays to ride the waves look at
me i've made it through
and so up and down the ticket federal
state local offices the country has to
repudiate this
okay so there will be no survivors guys
there can't be survivors we need to take
a list and check it twice and then
murder everyone
like does that sound like unity to you
joe biden's out there i like unity and
mashed potatoes and then you got over
here michelle obama going
half the country is motivated by hate
and chaos and division and they got
jennifer rubin out here going
there are no survivor aoc
did the same thing aoc i'm sorry i keep
calling her aoc
i keep forgetting it is sexist and mean
to call her by her twitter handle
aoc instead she's the honorable
representative alexandra ocasio-cortez
d-twitch
okay she tweeted out is anyone archiving
these trump sync fans for when they try
to downplay or deny their complicity in
the future
i foresee decent probability of many
deleted tweets ratings
photos in the future she's keeping a
list right we got to keep a list of
their bad tweets
of when they support trump lol at the
party of personal responsibility like
being upset at the idea of being
responsible for their behavior
over the last four years right this is a
call for revenge
anybody who supported trump at any point
must be revenged upon
vengeance hey elizabeth abrams
who's a former buddha judge campaign
staffer she tweeted out we're launching
the trump accountability project to make
sure anyone who took a paycheck to help
trump undermine america
is held responsible for what they did
join us and help spread the word
blacklists
this sounds like a party that's looking
for unification and healing
that like debathification right they're
looking for
unity through debatfification because
you understand trump was saddam hussein
and getting rid of trump that means that
anybody who ever liked trump or voted
for him
the 70 million americans voted for trump
70 million americans voted for donald
trump
you know who is the second largest
ballot winner in the history of the
united states
right now by popular vote count donald
trump he's won more votes than barack
obama ever did
okay some of that is due to population
growth some of that is because lots and
lots of people
voted for donald trump okay so you're
talking about 70 million
debatfification of 70 million americans
but but unity
guys unity peter beinart who is the uh
the
representative of hamas he tweeted out
in the 1990s i came to know many young
conservative journalists
now some are household names back then i
never imagined a moral test that would
so vividly expose their characters
some abetted tyranny others resisted it
trump x-rayed their souls i'll never
forget what i saw well i mean if peter
beinart
who still makes excuses for hamas
terrorists is saying that his x-rayed
souls then i guess that we'll have to
take him
at his word yes i see i foresee an era
of healing
and national unity or alternatively i
see an era in which joe biden
is driven by the left in his party to
wage war
upon all the values that many americans
hold dear especially in election where
americans rejected the progressive left
understand this is an election where
americans looked at the project at the
progressive left and they vomited on it
even in california they rejected a
couple of very progressive measures
right
there was one measure that was going to
kill uber and lyft they killed it
there's a measure that was going to
reinstall affirmative action in the
constitution of the state of california
essentially they rejected it
overwhelmingly
all across the country radicals were
rejected the democratic party
was handed a loss in the house in a year
where their top ballot getter
won a record number of votes more votes
than any other candidate in the history
of the republic and they lost
seats in the house they picked up two
seats in the senate and lost one in
alabama
okay that is not a victorious party the
democrats who are calling for healing
and reunification through
demathification
good luck with that good luck the battle
has just begun